le bureau yvelines information jeunesse
en danger c'est le message que ces
salariés souhaité faire passer en
manifestant ce matin dans les rues de
versailles même si le financement du
bureau reste assurée par les
collectivités y yj se heurte à un
problème de taille à compter du 1er
novembre les salariés n'auront plus de
direction et plus de direction signifie
qu en tant qu'association ils n'auront
légalement plus le droit d'exercer leur
mission en tant que salarié en fait on a
eu aucune information aucun retour sur
sur la suite sur le devenir des grecs
qui j on a lancé aussi une pétition
justement pour qu'on soit soutenue par
les partenaires par les usagers par les
amis de l'information jeunesse en
général et des grès clients particuliers
plus on aura de signataires plus on aura
en toi
la pétition lancée par yves une
information jeunesse a récolté 250
signataires selon laurence revin la ddcs
des yvelines a promis de se pencher d'un
peu plus près sur le cas des sept
salariés du bureau mais évoque un vide
juridique sur ce dossier y j espère être
reçue par le conseil général un de leurs
partenaires financiers pour rappel le
bureau assure une information aux jaloux
du département concernant l'orientation
l'emploi ou le logement